دمرت الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه عددا
من ابراج عين جالوت بمخيم نصيرات وسط قطاع
غزه كما شنت المقاتلات الاسرائيليه سلسله
غارات على مناطق مختلفه من قطاع غزه
استهدفت اغلبها منازل لفلسطينيين كما شنت
احزمه ناريه واطلقت قنابل دخانيه وفسفور
شرقيه مخيم نصرات وسط قطاع غزه وخانيونس
جنوب القطاع وقالت مصادر طبيه فلسطينيه ان
عددا من الشهداء والجرح وصلوا الى
المستشفيات جر استمرار الغارات
الاسرائيليه والقصف المدفعي على محافظات
القطاع كافه وفي وقت سابق افاد مراسل
الجزيره بسقوط ثلاثه شهداء اثر استهداف
منزل لعائله النحال في منطقه خربه العدس
شرق رفح جنوبي قطاع
غزه معنا من دير البلح مراسل الجزيره هشام
زقوط هشام ما اخر المعلومات حول اثار هذا
القصف الاسرائيلي
المستمر بالفعل القصف اسرائيلي مستمر
ومتواصل على انحاء مختلفه من قطاع غزه لا
سيما مخيم البريج الذي يتعرض الى قصف عنيف
من المدفعيه الاسرائيليه بالاضافه الى
مخيم المغازي ايضا الذي يتعرض الى قصف
عنيف اطلاق نار اطلاق قنابل دخانيه وايضا
قنابل فسفوريه وبعض ال الاضرار والدمار
مشاهد الدمار في المدارس التابعه لوكاله
غوث وتشغيل للاجئين الانرو التي تعرضت
للقصف فجر هذا اليوم من جراء القصف
المدفعي وحتى من الطائرات الحربيه
الاسرائيليه التي قصفت محيط هذه المدارس
وايضا القصف المدفعي الذي تعرضت له منازل
بالقرب من هذه المدارس وبالتالي كانت هناك
اضرار جسيمه في هذه المدارس التي تؤوي
نازحين فلسطينيين العشرات من الخيام التي
كانت في ساحه هذه المدرسه في مخيم المغازي
وسط قطاع غزه تضررت بفعل هذه بفعل القصف
المدفعي الع عنيف الذي يتعرض له مخيم
المغازي استطاعت ايضا الطواقم الطبيه
انتشال اربعه جثامين من مخيم المغازي جراء
استمرار القصف الاسرائيلي المدفعي على تلك
المنطقه مخيم البريج ليس افضل حالا لكن
الدخول الى مخيم البريج بات مستحيلا بفعل
الاستمرار القصف الاسرائيلي وايضا
الطائرات المسيره التي تطلق النار على كل
ما يتحرك في تلك المناطق وبالتالي التحرك
والدخول الى هذا المخيم بات مستحيلا ومهمه
صعبه للغايه حتى لطواقم اسعاف وطواقم
الدفاع المدني التي كانت تعمل في كل صباح
على عمليات تمشيط لمناطق التي تتعرض للقصف
الاسرائيلي وبالتالي تعمل على انتشال
الجثامين واجلاء مصابين ان كان هناك
مصابين في تلك المناطق بالتالي الان مخيم
البريج بات محاصرا لا يمكن الدخول اليه لا
يمكن الخروج منه هناك محاولات حثيثه من
الطواقم للتنسيق من اجل الدخول وانتشال
بعض الجثامين لان بحسب شهود العيان ما
زالت هناك جثامين ملقاه على الارض
وتعمل الطواقم الطبيه على التنسيق من اجل
انتشالها ايضا مخيم النصيرات ربما هو كان
مسرحا للاحداث الابرز والاخطر في هذه خلال
الساعات الماضيه لا سما وان ابراج عنين
جالوت تعرضت الى قصف عنيف من المدفعيه
الاسرائيليه ايضا شنت الطائرات الحربيه
الاسرائيليه غارات عنيفه واحزمه ناريه في
تلك المنطقه وادت الى دمار كبير في هناك
الدمار في الابراج وايضا دمار في المنازل
المحيطه بهذه الابراج بالاضافه الى لان
القصف المدفعي مازال مستمرا على تلك
المناطق نشكرك حتى اللحظه من ذر البلح
مراسل الجزيره هشام زقو